did you see the gallop most admired man
of the year
who was it who do you think obama
uh trump was ranked
as the most admired man of the year
2020.
congratulations donald trump great job
now here's a it's a question for you
there's a question for you because
i know would you say gallup is a
left-leaning or a right-leaning
organization if you were to gallop
probably center left i would assume
where would you put gallop far left far
left really yeah
let's just give me some give you some
data on why this is so ridiculous that
they came up with this
so history of the most admired
men of all time okay last year i'll just
give you last year
trump was this year the year before was
trump and obama a tie
last year 2019 they tied best friends so
for men most admired men of all time is
eisenhower
12 times obama 12 times
reagan eight times clinton eight times
two republicans two democrats okay
bush seven times republican johnson
lyndon four times democrat nixon
four times george h.w bush four times
macarthur
three times carter three times kissinger
non-president three times john f kennedy
three
uh uh two truman two trump two
john pope john paul the second
very favorite yeah it's one time okay
but what do you mean one
of the year yeah of the year how are
people winning it that's like
like 100 years right you could win it
five years in a row you could win it ten
years in order
you said you said obama won it twelve
times time how's that even possible
he actually yeah like two years ago his
numbers don't work
if you want to know obama started
winning the most admired man since 2008
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19.
12 times it's that he's won it even when
he was out of office
yes he's going to get it now the most
admired women
who do you think is at the top and it's
not even a close race hillary clinton
it's not even a close race michelle is
it michelle or is it hillary who do you
think is at the top
hillary michelle winfrey hello let's go
through it
number one oprah but oprah's never
wanted once that was a trick question
oh my god he got me so watch this
hillary clinton
120 125 times uh 22
times hillary clinton these numbers
don't make sense eleanor roosevelt 13
thatcher six jackie kennedy five mother
teresa four nancy reagan four rosalind
rosalind
carter three times golda mere three time
michelle obama three betty four two
barbara bush two
mammy eisenhower ii pat nixon laura bush
ethel kennedy
elizabeth kenney all won but hillary
clinton
has been the most admired woman
from 2002 all the way down to 2017 until
michelle obama you know what's crazy
every year every year this is such a big
surprise
that's your community pelosi isn't on
the list yeah
hey you know what's crazy that's a good
point hillary clinton
has been the most admired woman in the
world 22 times
she's not even in the top 10 in her own
house as far as
i don't 22 times makes notes
trump's made it on that list one time
trump's made it two times now
and what do you think about that eric i
know you're excited about hillary
clinton 22 times
it carries as much weight as people
magazine's sexiest man of the year right
i mean
i don't know i'm surprised the rock
isn't number one
he's probably working his way most of my
most famous would probably be the rock
he
they say 57 percent of the world
recognizes his face
he's the most recognizable face wow
number one
more than obama oh yeah he's number one
more than trump hey do you guys remember
the rock when he was a wrestler
do you remember how yeah yeah yeah we do
tom yeah no but i mean for real like did
you watch
wrestling he was the funniest yeah but i
mean like really
good i don't even watch wrestling i
would love to see part of that persona
come out
god he was so dead what do you mean by
part of that persona oh just the trash
talking the character
the thing that he used to do with coach
remember the the announcer
for the wwe uh he was just so you
couldn't watch that and not think he's
going to be the biggest movie star in
the world
but you know what he's a tactician
there's a bigger end game for him i
think you think he's going to run for
president eventually don't you
who the rock yeah yeah if there is
if i could bet on him running not him
winning if i could bet on him running
i'd put a million dollars on her right
now and it almost if i could bet on him
right sure
and it's almost like his his stance
would be i'm doing this for america i
have to do this i have no choice but to
run
you know and i i think there's a very
good chance too because are you
where are you you know what he could
start with he could start with governor
of california when we get newsome out by
the end of the year i think that's too
boring
i know it is i think that's too boring
for you i don't think he's excited
president or bust huh
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye